foreign
[Music]
hey Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hey Barbie hi Barbie
hi Ken
goes cruising just as fast as she can
now
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriend
I'm actually not sure
[Music]
okay ladies let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
here I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
oh looks like this beach is a little too
much Beach for you Ken if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
right now Ken I'll beat you off with you
any day Ken anyone who wants to beat him
up has to beat me off first I will beat
both of you off at the same time
[Music]
thank you